yeah Faso was thank you very much for
the invitation
yeah I came from Tokyo just for this
talk basically I arrived yesterday and I
fly back tomorrow morning so I really
want to hear from you so I stay here
after this talk and I also get questions
during my talk so please yeah please let
me hear your voice so yeah I'm working
on somewhere between HCI and graphics I
try to balance between these two fears
so yeah for HCI I want to make computers
or computer system is easier to use and
in computer graphics I'm more interested
in like 3d shape processing and also
communications using graphics and here's
a kind of background or motivation of
all the walks in our group so yeah this
is very general discussion but this
society today is a mass production and
mass consumption and we do see the same
thing all all over the world I see
Eclair shops everywhere in u.s. in Japan
were China were Europe the same thing
and also a nice aim yeah comments
towards work well it's the same cars and
yeah this may be efficient but I don't
think it's very interesting so one
possible future vision is that everybody
and the users become designers and
producers and then they create things
satisfy their own needs and obviously
this is not very new vision many people
say the same thing using different
keywords like computer generated
contents approach sumos surdo falls in
in this revolution and they are already
existing platforms to support this kind
of activity like 3d printing or laser
cutting however the problem is it's easy
to up share existing shapes or designs
of print and get it and use it but still
we believe the design or creating
something new by yourself is still
difficult problem we want to address so
our goal is to help people design and
fabricate what they need and then we
want to develop computers to to achieve
discourses that's cool and then let's me
go more into details
so yeah this is I know just too much
simplification but typical pipeline of
computational design is like this the
users request give requests to the
computer and then computer do some some
logic like optimization or something and
then you will get something result and
we are talking about active part can be
graphics like amazing shapes in
computers what this can be a physical
always a Christ garments or chairs or
was anything and then the computational
tool can be optimization and simulation
machine a knows however so in this
typical traditional view not much
interaction after system gets requests
so what we want to do in our series of
project is a human in the loop
computational design which means we want
to integrate more humor in this process
and so that sub you and there are
certain benefits in this way of doing
compared to fully automatic ones so
first one most importantly is we want to
support creative exploration right you
know people not really knows what they
really want at the beginning so it's
very difficult to give requirements
clearly before you start working on it
so that's why important part so you want
support creative exploration and then
even if the goal is clear it may be
difficult for computers to do it alone
so we want to exploit human perception
and also we want to explore human body
capability in the fabrication process so
that's introduction so now let me move
into the specific projects we are
working on with students and yeah
honestly not so organized maybe you know
each student in my group work on
different things so just a collection
many different things but I hope you see
some consistent taste or a vision behind
them so the first Bronco project is
designed with physical simulation so the
idea is like this so computer-aided
design now designing something computer
is not new
so you know people design
in computers today but still most
existing design tools doesn't consider
physics during design phase so it's
basically just drafting or drawing
software you just put arbitrary lines
boxes lines and shapes but they don't
care about simulation simulation often
comes later after you get something and
then move on to simulation and they
maybe go back later but this psycho was
not so close so what we want to do is
integrate real time physical simulation
into a design system so that you get
instant continuous feedback from system
to design some physical functioning
objects the first project we walked on
one is this kind of fresh toy design
system so if you want to design a fresh
dough you have to consider both 2d
pattern and then without in 3d shape
which may be easy for experienced people
but for novice users for kids it's very
difficult so we integrate kind of simple
physical simulation to predict 3d shape
from 2d pattern and then you get a very
nice design system and that's a video so
so the interface is taken from what's
happening the interface is taken from
sketching interface modeling one so you
sketch something and then you will get a
3d shape here but at the same time
system also generates automatically
generate 2d cross pattern what creating
these stuffed animals internally we run
some basic simulation to predict the 3d
shape taken from this to the pattern and
then we implemented a couple gestural
interactions to get 3d shape and then
you eventually get these double stuffed
animal here 3d one and they also you get
a 2d pattern so after finishing design
you can print this pattern and then cut
cross material and stitch theater and
push cotton in it and there you will get
a 3d shape and then here is the result
so after some editing operations you can
get reasonable
3d shape here and then you get I don't
show here but the system also shows
which one is connected which edge and so
on so it provides some guide and then
you eventually get reasonable 3d shape
and then after spending some hours then
you get physical stuff to animal as well
and using the same pattern you can also
make a big balloon you will see here
yeah again traditionally traditionally
design of this kind of thing requires
expressional experience and knowledge
but with this tool you just get
something you want and then you get
physical stuffed animal and we did some
small user study we provided these two
two kids and they successfully generated
their own customized one-of-a-kind
stuffed animals you know traditionally
it's very difficult to design new ones
so they usually use just by existing
template and they just created a copy of
some existing animal stuff presto but
here these are their own you know
they're their own lovely yeah stuffed
animals and also we found that this this
activity is very nice family event you
know family members walk together some
yeah someone walking on computer system
and then some people are walking on the
swing and it was a nice experience so
that's one thing okay so next one so
next why it's a kind of strange problem
which wanted address but suppose you
want design a customized musical
instruments in this case metal phone
with special shape and please also
imagine that this is a very difficult
problem right it's very hard to predict
which sound this each bar produces
without actually fabricated and hit this
bar however computer can predict the
sound so we integrate physical
simulation into the design system so
that people can design music musical
instruments that produce appropriate
sound and also have a nice look so
that's the idea
and a feedback imputed so here the user
is designing a bar of a metal phone and
the system runs the other time physical
simulation predicts at all and this is a
visualization of a vibration and the
other subsystem gives our audio feedback
oh phone it's calculated via eigen value
analysis as the user a distance more
than the tallest immediately computes
its I am not showing the right window
which tells how the middle of each code
to provide the other Barbeques system in
the state because the change of tone
caused by the shape eric is very
difficult to predict we believe
designing a marathon with a desired
shape and tone so this visualization is
also important to identify where to fix
this middle bar into the base to be
possible only with our responsive a free
end result here are the design middle
from pieces by an artist and then we
actually actual creation despair
analysis successfully simulates the real
world yeah but however the one problem
is that if you look carefully each this
kind of strange shaped plates produces
different tone depending where you hit
so you have to care for a hit specific
for the press you if you see the video
again you know these guys carefully hit
specific place right yeah so this is for
analysis access please see ways the real
world so again this visualization tells
you where you hit you know the highest
linear vibration point is a we are to
press so possible next project is to
have a single afraid and then produce
different tone depending where you hit
that's one possible direction to go
but that something okay and we apply the
same idea to a garment design the idea
is exactly the same so user continuously
edits a 2d pattern and the system
continuously presents a simulation
result to the user
yeah pajama
so yeah the user added to the garment
pattern here and their system
continuously provides prediction in the
draping simulation result traditionally
this kind of design is done physically
you know people cut clothes and they put
it on the mannequin and this is the
result and it go back to the pattern but
here you can just continuously see the
result of winkles if it's too tight it's
loose here and then you get immediate
feedback if it's too short and they'll
get the shape and you get immediate or
if it's a result and I think this is
very helpful for creative exploration so
maybe trivial or easy to experts may not
need this but you know nobody's no
experience user can't imagine this in
their heads but this kind of
visualization is very helpful and this
kind of tool is particularly useful for
strange garments like pajama for
armadillo and you know one knows how to
design a shirt for this guy so the whole
time physical ratio is very helpful you
know
yeah games getting more sophisticated
and they need they they often use
physical simulation then physically
realistic government is necessary for
this kind of storage guys too and we
actually fabricated this of course it's
not exact perfect much but you can see
overall shape is reasonable and we also
created your garment yeah reasonable
thing
and they eventually you get finalized
out was it yeah it takes sort of all
time yeah so we made it
yeah he's rotating by himself we don't
have a nice studio that's fun okay let
me move on so this is yeah gay another
craft work suppose you want to design a
special customized paper glider and
again I I hope you understand that this
is a very difficult highly constrained
program in a very slight change in
attachment angle changes a flight
trajectory so it's very difficult to
design a very friable Grider's so we
provide integrated physical simulation
into it to make it possible for
everybody to design friable tiramisu so
let's see video so the first one is a
failure case so if you design
arbitrarily I pray it doesn't fly just
drops and it's very hard to design but
here is a result using our system we
design a llama diddle I pray and then
you get really bright well and so that's
a result our design to is right it's the
same idea so user interactively edit
shape of wing and attachment angle
positions and then here is a
visualization of flight simulation this
is a side view so the it starts from
here and therefore I so this is failure
case it's just go to up and they go down
so ideally this grade I should go all
the way to the other end and this many
lines many curves indicated variations
you know this is hands wrong Grider so
we consider we it may be better to
consider multiple trajectory at a time
to see variations and user basically
edit
the wing and shape body shape looking at
the simulation result so that it
actually flies really well
yeah it's getting better it's writes
better and then you change the shape and
you also change the position on the
shape however in some cases it's very
rare it's very hard to do get the re
frying Grider by hand so we put can you
ladies make with fry high so he press
this button and the system automatically
applies optimization to this process and
their system gets you a get early very
friable yeah
Grider so yeah what carefully as soon as
you hit this photon system automatically
adjusts the wing angle or position
slightly yes you see as soon as you put
push that port on check mark and then
yeah system are just a wing and then you
will get and this is more interesting so
use a manual drugs front wing and the
system automatically adjust idea wing so
this is interesting collaboration
between human and machine yeah so the
front wings manually controlled and this
one is not much card controls and the
system is always yeah it's not good
shape this is the weight so yeah after
getting a design it's easy to fabricate
just send data to a laser cutter and
then you will get a shape and they are
sampled manually and they final result
so this is Almaty Roma so this is a
launcher and then this is our classroom
and then starts from here it fries
really well and more better than we
expected and then yeah we are very happy
is that sound for Dragon yeah yeah
that's right very well yeah it's fun
project yeah that's it and so yeah this
one this work was getting reasonably
popular but people get expect too much
as you engineers understand this one
doesn't make impossible possible right
we just explore possible physically
possible space it easier but yeah like
TV crew come to me and want to shoot
introduce this video they they request
us to create crazy things and I have to
tell you know this tooth can't try
anything right here we only can do
limited things so that's the interesting
story a technically interesting aspect
of this project is we took data driven
approach things the usual can control
and which things you're optimized in
that case yeah like you chose to like
certain things be optimized and certain
things to control right we don't do
anything complicated here I think in
this case you if his user it's directly
controlling something it's the control
by user and the system controls the
other saying and then just system picks
what I think steepest descent most
simple thing yeah yeah yeah pieces yeah
another thing so you have to make some
decisions about what to keep fixed the
idea
the more sophisticated mechanism but in
this particular implementation we don't
allow the system to change the shape you
just just what things you would allow
the vary and what things you would allow
them fix well again in this particular
project for the scale implementation you
know changing shape is to hide the high
degree of freedom so not good for
optimization crease so we took the
easiest one actual adjusting angle but
yeah you are right it's very important
questions which one allow system to
change and which one should not be
changed at that's future work right you
know you set up the HDI part by saying
that we're trying to make things more
expensive get your exact early but part
of that is making these decisions about
what's gonna be unlimited users which
are you looking for some sort of like
design principle of how we make that
trade-off yeah you know just understand
it okay yeah so again technically
interesting aspect of this project was
we took data-driven approach
so yeah previous systems are admitted of
whom were close and we just use standard
analytic simulation methods and also we
tested actually tried standard fluid
dynamics simulation for this project at
the beginning but it was way too slow
right there's no way to predict or
trajectory when multiple trajectory in
year time for your real-time input so we
took that adorable plots so where we
fabricated many many papaya prior
actually and then be decoded flight
trajectory and then we estimated many
coefficients for necessary for
simulation and then we get this data
driven approach for quick prediction of
right trajectory and so we don't I don't
want to ride on the airplane
one designed using this this method so
accurate but I think it's really
appropriate for designing a toy airplane
I think it's efficient and appropriate
okay so now our next prop is a
crowdsourcing I'm hesitated to show this
because we have a expert here but I want
to show at least what we tried so yeah
so we worked on some computation design
as always crowds yeah partly inspired by
lots of interesting work from your group
so we I wanted to projects from our guru
so wise parametric design and wine shape
modeling so first one is a parametric
design so the problem we wanted address
in this project is a parametric design
and parametric design your parameter
tweaking happens in many many different
applications so one example is image
editing so if you want to edit image you
have to control many many parameters
like brightness contrast white balance
we are many things and many sliders and
it's very tedious for novice users and
even experts this code to keep track of
everything so we want to help computer
support and also this is another example
a material design or PRS design in
graphics if you want to help the
appearance like ya glossiness or color
or many other parameters and then it's
very difficult so we want to do it
easier and in this particular
implementation project we focused on
crowdsourcing so we decompose this
complicated high dimension or such tasks
into simple micro tasks and they ask
crowd to walk on it by the way I want to
emphasize that same method can be
applicable for our self sourcing you
know you can do it manually just by
simple tasks rather than single big
massive complicated tasks so that's the
thing and of course question is how to
decompose a task into micro tasks that
the main problem and specific
contributions we claimed in this
publication paper is what is micro task
design is another is algorithm oh so for
fast one
he proposed a new method and then we
also implemented algorithm to achieve
that so the first one so I think we
believe that if Cara traditional
approach to get crowd feedback is this
kind of pairwise comparison you know we
show two samples in this huge parameter
space and asked a crowd worker to pick
the best one I think this is a popular
approach and lisa-marie works well
however from the system with the point
of view the information the system we
can get from this single input is very
small this is one bit information and we
thought well it's very efficient and
just why depressing this radio button to
adjust salida just very small change in
UI system can get much richer
information from the user so user just
explores a parameter 1 dimensional
parameter space using slider 1 dimension
space was a high dimensional space and
there you can get one and yeah we expect
that there's maybe slightly more
overhead from users point of view but
the benefit outweighs the slight
increase of user overhead so that's the
idea and then inside the system we apply
busy optimization method I'm curious how
many of you are familiar with page
optimization everyone knows everyone sir
thank you very much
I didn't notice before this project but
this is a kind of established technique
and we extend this to support this
one-dimensional subspace so basic idea
is to you know the system gets
estimation or was a goodness of fitness
in this high dimensional parameter space
and then whenever you get input from the
user system gets some estimation and
then decide which which parameter space
1 dimensional parameter subspace to
present depending on this current
internal model so this is kind of active
learning kind of framework so you know
here's a kind of visualization so so
this this color coded to D so this is a
two dimensional view of this ID so yeah
this is
actually a high-dimensional but this is
2d visualization and this is this
color-coded tight field is invisible
unknown ground truth so the goal is to
find this place and for a system
randomly placed some random one
dimensional subspace and the user pick
this point and the system estimates the
current guess is here and the system
puts another one-dimensional subspace in
this subspace to get maximum information
from the user and the system controls
the sliders to get one and then given
these input system updates the
prediction and then present an X 1
dimensional subspace and then use a
pixel-based one in this subspace and
then go to the next and eventually by
repeating iterating this process system
gets better model and you will get a
better result so we did some evaluation
we compared our situation line search
and pairwise comparison and the way also
four-way comparison and there is a
result and I think we we were all so
excited about this result which was
better than we expected originally so a
sequence analysis gets much faster to
converge and also combines the much
better error compared to pairwise
comparison or four-way sync and this one
checks the task completion time of each
cloud worker for each task and as we
expected the overhead crowd Walker time
for a sequential risers slider task is
slightly larger than pairwise comparison
Warfel way but it's not like double or
triple
it's a little bit and it you know the
benefit outweighs this overhead so that
our result yeah yeah let me skip yeah
well interesting applications like this
we can request users to tweak appearance
material design tasks giving by giving
this kind of natural language request to
the crowd workers so proud worker was
for example asked
please Peaks rider just write us as much
as possible that result looks like a
gold and then you know crowd work I'd
rather just walk on a single slider and
they we accumulate it and they
eventually you get this kind of same so
from the users point of view this is
like a natural language interface for
getting material design you you're
exploring has like a single Optima and
not like several do you have some way of
guaranteeing that this is a positive
show aesthetics thing so there's no
guarantees that there's a single maximum
so we yeah third party is kind of weak
we just just do it assuming that some
smooth space with single maximum and
yeah three to mean to multiple maximum
results not yet done yeah that's
possible direction to go simplified
setting only a single maximum that was
assumption behind okay so another one is
yeah crowd mode collaboratives 3d
modeling and I must admit that this was
not so successful project but it was
interesting so I want to share it so the
motivation is 3d modeling it's still
tedious I have been walking was really
more than water on 10 years 20 years was
still it's hard so we so it might be
interesting as crowd Walker's to do it
as a micro tasks so that's a research
question
so yeah let's take campos 3d modeling
into crowd hugs and then see what
happens so this is more like
intellectual curiosity I want to see is
it possible or not and how good it is so
that's and then there are many ways but
we tested this very simple task so
suppose you want to design this kind of
furniture from photograph we asked grant
Walker to sketch side view in this case
this
aroma liqui mein means that please draw
aside a front view of this chair and
then we provide a very very simple very
basic drawing editor just just rectangle
and oval and then we ask user to give a
2d sketch so this is this is a micro
tasks and each crowd worker only works
on a single view so there's no
consistency between side-view and
front-view on top view so in this way we
correct many many front view many many
side abuse and many many top view
independently and then we assemble them
together to get 3d shapes that's what we
experimented and here is a kind of days
out like we asked cloud workers to draw
side view and many of them collect to
redraw side of you but some
misunderstand request a completely
random very bad so it's actually very
challenging to get meaningful result
from this kind of messy input from a
crowd of workers so we do some many like
a clustering thing and do many things
but still the result was like this so we
tried as best as possible technique that
clustering or do my do our best but from
the initial result we got this is a
maximum we get so it was too poor we
failed
so we implemented more iterations so we
integrate it this is I think very
standard in crowdsourcing Saints but we
get evaluators and then we pick good
sketches and we presented it to the next
crowd workers as a good examples please
see these examples and then we get more
data and then we repeat this and then we
eventually get better result and by
integrating this mechanism we managed to
get better and better result and after
South iteration we finally get the
result but as even noticed it costs a
lot actually
so that's the conclusion so yeah we
managed to get this diamond shape with
this is 3/3
two iterations five iterations fighters
we get this but it cost a lot we did
test it crowd-sourced result and then we
also requested single expert to do it
and yeah honestly this was a failure the
cost was higher and oh by the way
so we first submit this work to cry why
USD but we were rejected only because
the payment to the crowd worker was too
low so we have to redo the study again
with recommended price range and then
the cost was high that was a reality and
also however so this is the quality was
higher by experts a cost was lower for
expert but we found some benefit of
crowdsourcing is a town our a long time
you know if you request require high
expert we need free time of this
particular expert finding expert it
takes time first and then the expert
have to work on certain amount of time
concentrate it took time so it in this
case in this particular study to almost
one day but crowd workers we can pick
arbitrary person anywhere so we get
final result much faster and also a
human labor from users point of view was
much less here it's all almost fully
automated we use adjust extend request
and then get we started to have people
draw stuff too and finished and for
expert is totally working at this time
is where we were user-centered start
recruiting or send a request and then
the time we could use all the time to
find expert and then the time ends when
we gets a result
this image was sketch or two-dimensional
thing and they output this video so
assumption is that we don't know the
ground true 3d model we only have a reg
photograph of something yes 3d modeling
from photographs that's a task
this is subjective quality yeah if you
look this carefully zooming lots of
parts are missing here so this is just
qualitative subjective variation in this
case it's obvious so many missing parts
consistency yeah yeah so let me let me
go back yeah here it's almost automated
it's very easy to do but here you have
to negotiate explain at ask the expert
negotiate infer their skill from
communication so there are lots of
puncayshun so I think we do have
benefits and yeah maybe yeah that's a
result okay so finally smart devices so
so now we we discussed about the
fabrication actual creation process and
again typical pipelines like this user
design something in computers and then
computer sends the data to the
fabrication device like 3d printer and
you get a final result so this is the
kind of one-way pipeline so we want to
make it interactive by having a smart
tool to use a directory interact with
the physical object with computationally
supported to this may be very
interesting so that's the idea and we
are not the first of this kind so we are
certainly inspired by previous
interesting works like computer
supported a cutting machine or computer
supported the meeting machine so human
computer work together to fabricate so
it's there already so we did some
different things so first why is this
one I think it's sort of exploratory
from this photograph but the person is
drawing system or copied yeah so yeah
petitions come from here so you can draw
something on the carpet and you can
quickly raise it and they've implemented
three devices the first one is a master
display so we put many rods and then
it's if you rotate and they go up and
down along the way and then you can
leave a trace bitmap happen and then you
can get interesting illustrations like
this way yeah
so we call this a very environment
friendly display because no power
consumption and there's no ink waste
it's reusable
it's very nice it's very large screen
and it was fun
it takes time but so that's one is out
and next one is a vector graphics so
it's basically pen type device you
arbitrary drawing and then the rotating
wheel places afar and the most important
part is orientation it's stabilized I
hope you understand that so yeah however
orientation you hold the pen the tip is
always be consistent orientation so that
it always raises far whichever direction
you go which orientation you hold the
pen so it's a very high-tech device for
copy drawing so you know if you use just
a finger you can leave a trace in one
direction but you cannot do in another
direction but here you can always leave
traces so this is a interesting express
you know this is like a copy it becomes
a whiteboard so you can draw whatever
and here is even more high-tech things
this is a remote this is speaker
ultrasound speaker array can produce
force in this time so you can remotely
activate it for oh it is so far so yeah
this is too much technology for simple
things
but it's fun project so yeah that's it
okay so yeah we are running out of time
so let me accelerate so we also
collaborated with architecture people to
create huge ones so this is a fun
project medians chopsticks so here you
see the scale this is a person and this
is like a four meter tall large scale a
video made of chopsticks and here's a
pipeline so we this is this project
consists of three components why the
material design so this is a composite
of chopsticks and glue and we tested
many mixture and been a different way of
dropping and we actually we collaborated
with professional structure engineers to
see material property of this one and
also we'd built a dispenser dropping
grew and chopsticks together and then we
implemented a guiding system combining
Kinect sensor and also projector to
guide people to drop chopsticks and then
you eventually get this huge are
chopsticks architecture next project we
walked on with architectural group is a
huge scale 3 duro I think you know 3 do
draw this is the handheld 3d printer you
can trace 3d wire in midair so we wanted
to make a big one so you can see the
scale so people is here it's a huge huge
one so it's a video is reckless I want
to draw a pillow here and you just do
this and you get a period here and you
can do this and you'll get the next one
and this is the implementation so it's
actually dangerous so this shape and but
as you see it this device does create a
Peter in midair it's not easy to
actually draw a free-form curve but as
you see it does work so what we do is
just standard a form see a lapidary
solidifying form and then but if you do
nothing it just drops
so we wrap this with mesh to stabilize
and then you can do something like this
and it is fully experimental project and
I think this is a finer one yeah
publication with natural shape runs it
so traditional building is built with
very standardized you know straight line
pillars or wood materials so in this
project instead we want to liberate
naturally shaped curved branches for
architectural elements this might be
difficult in the past however we we have
now achieved 3d scanning and 3d milling
machine combining this fabrication
devices we thought that it might be
possible to use these natural shape
branches for as architecture element and
here's a nice video
[Music]
that we do coming here to get a 3d shape
after scanning we move into the design
process implemented the final
gamification thing the system provides
feedback about the structure
[Music]
the system automatically joints
so this is an initial experiment so we
cannot do complicate this thing so we
are still ongoing project so we try to
build Raja one based on this kind of
technology so yeah so that's that must
mostly it so we are walking on
human-in-the-loop confident design for
our end-users to design something with
physical simulation and crowd sourcing
and smart devices and yeah so just
briefly want to other besides our
current work so we are staying away from
machine learning for a while but now we
started working HTF for machine learning
I just heard the similar thing is
happening here James and as a people
walking on but I I try to do something
like that and a goal here is the making
machine learning easier to use so you
know I have been working on making
computer graphics easier to use for
novice users so I want to do similar
thing for machine learning so currently
if somebody wants to use machine
learning system used system you need
it's better to hire a machine an expert
what is some knowledgeable person but I
hope people can easily more easily can
use machine learning techniques and
here's a different view so there are
many people using machine learning for
each year application like a gesture
recognition activity recognition many
visual tasks but that's not what we want
to do I want to do more like the
opposite direction you know even if
machine learning may do something
menacing automatically but building
machine learning system needs lots of
human intervention human efforts so we
want to develop tools to help these
people using machine learning so yeah
that's the idea
so yeah there are many factors that help
people to get data on machine training
and also interface to help control
learning and also help user interface
actually using an edge adjusting the
result of machine learning operations so
this project just started and we are
hiring so that's why I'm here
way so if you're interested in this kind
of project and want to spend some time
in Tokyo we always expecting visitors
interns postdocs so please come to Tokyo
so thank you wait a time okay that's it